hey guys in this video i'm going to show
you how to shave your beard clean yes
i'm going to shave all my facial hair
and show you how to do it the proper way
without getting any razor bumps
and to be honest i don't really want to
do it i don't want to shave this beard
because i worked so hard
to just grow it and maintain it to look
at the way that it looks right now but i
have to because i lost a bet a fishing
competition with the mums
so i don't really want to do it but
my word is my bond as they say so
let's get to it
[Music]
all right are you guys ready to see what
i look like without a beard
well i'm not but it's going to be
interesting young baby face probably but
anyway let's start this thing so how do
you shave your beard clean there are six
steps that you need to follow
step one use a trimmer to trim your long
hair shorter because
if you don't and you just use a blade
you'll be in for a world of pain so trim
it as short as you can
[Music]
step two soften your beard so that it is
easier and less painful when you shave
how do you do that easy just shave it
right after the shower or
wash your facial hair with lukewarm to
warm water to get it soft
[Music]
step 3 put in good quality shaving cream
this is important for a gentle shave
step 4
shave with the grain of your hair never
against it because if you do you will
get ingrained hair
do this step by step until your facial
hair is gone
and never use an old shaver make sure
the blades are sharp
[Music]
step 5 wash off all the face cream and
the remaining hair and then dry your
face gently by just patting it with a
towel
step 6 use your skincare routine's face
cream i use geology which has been
uniquely created for my skin concerns
geology is the brand that i use for my
skincare routine and you can order it
directly from their website i have a
very good relationship with them and i
got you guys a 70
special discount code if you want to try
it out you can find it in the video
description below if you don't want to
try them you can also check out pc for
men
clinique
or tj hanley i've added all the
information for you in the video
description down below so you can go
check it out your own research and see
for yourself now now you know how to
shave your beard clean the right way but
be honest do you like this bearded look
or
do you like this
shaven look i think he looks like a baby
face
baby face look who's talking grandpa
well
with a beard at least i look like a real
man
a real man is defined by a character not
by facial hair yeah well i can't argue
with that can i
alright guys if you want to know how to
maintain grow your beard check out this
video here
and we'll see you there and always
remember before you go life is short so
don't waste yours cheers guys